(SINGING) Oh, oh, oh my goodness.
Oh my word.
Gracious me, what is this genius we all have just heard?
It gave me the chills.
It gave me the feels.
It made me both weep and kick up my heels
'cause you are the music.
You are the pulse and the pitch and the time
and the tune and the groove.
And look at you move.
You are the music.
If your song were a painting, I would
think it should be hung in the Louvre.
You are the music.
Now, wait a second.
Buddy, look at you.
You've got skills I'm playing second fiddle to.
I cry when you croon, I sing when you strum,
and what's that cool fingering you did with your thumb?
Yeah, you are the music.
You've got a knack for the notes and a tantalizing
touch with a tune.
You got me over the moon.
You are the music.
Roll over, Beethoven, Mick Jagger, and Miss Debby Boone.
You are awesome.
You are awesomer.
Your music flies to me on wings of gossamer.
You're iconic.
You're, like, bionic.
You'll be my dominant, I'll be your tonic.
We are the music.
We'd like to learn music.
We bring the lightning, the fire, the water, the earth,
and the air.
There's no getting through.
We are the music.
Will we learn some music?
We're Billy Joel, Yo-Yo Ma, 50 Cent, Chubby Checker, and Cher.
Now what'll we do?
We are the music.
Forte.
Piano.
We are the music.
(QUIETLY) Pianissimo.
Where did the children go?